ready to roll
all right thanks very much roy and
thanks everyone for your time and
welcome to this session on spanner pocs
i'm nevin heinz i'm a senior engineer at
google on the spanner team
so today we're going to discuss how to
plan and run a spanner poc and the talk
is roughly in three parts
first we'll talk about pocs in general
why you want to do a poc what would you
learn from it what are some of the
typical goals and how you plan one
and next to make this a bit more
concrete i'm going to walk through an
example of some typical steps in a poc
i'm i'm going to use this using a sample
gaming application that's loosely based
on nfl fantasy football
um and then part three i'll conclude
with some observations on best practices
and tooling and then open it up for
questions
all right so let's set some context
first
so
if we zoom out a little
then it's useful to recognize the role
of a poc
as part of the big picture of a spanner
migration so usually the poc is fairly
early on in a migration
i've got on this slide a typical set of
steps of a migration and not all
migrations have exactly these steps in
exactly this order but
in general this flow is pretty common
these steps are fairly independent of
the source and target databases and i'm
sure for some of you these steps will be
pretty familiar
what i'm going to do is go over these
steps and highlight them from the
perspective of migrations to spanner so
most migrations start with some kind of
assessment phase so the goal here is to
determine if the target database in this
case spanner is likely to be a good fit
will it provide the necessary
functionality will it meet cost
performance requirements
how much work will the migration be what
are the biggest risks what are the
biggest benefits
so the next step is often a proof of
concept and in many ways this is like an
extension of the assessment so it's
typical for the proof of concept to
focus on key items that came up in the
assessment like the biggest risks um or
confirming the main benefits can be
delivered
so a proof of concept is often like a
feasibility study for the full migration
we want to use it as a vehicle to
understand to explore key technical
issues and trade-offs and basically to
set up a blueprint for the rest of the
migration
all right so what are the remaining
steps of a migration after a poc
um and i've split this into a couple of
steps on this slide so in step three on
this slide it's kind of the core part of
the migration preparation so design
implementation of the migration so you
know this can have many components
and there's some common themes here
designing spanish schema figuring out
how to move data from
your current database into spanner
building components to support that move
and the third is application changes to
switch over to using spanner so it's
typical to prototype approaches to much
of this work in the poc
now the next step step four is testing
and dry runs and successful migrations
involve significant testing either using
test traffic or parts of your production
load and it's common for steps three and
four to be intermixed so you might have
an initial design and implementation try
it out find issues go back do some
redesign change the implementation so
this is really an iterative process
and finally many migrations have a kind
of a target day for moving data or
completing a data move and switching
over to using spanner so this is a
really critical day at sort of a
convergence of all of the planning and
execution phases of a migration and a
key part of this is knowing how to
respond if things don't go according to
plan what signals and dashboards should
we be looking at what's the criteria for
reverting how do we revert so if you'd
like to hear more uh detailed discussion
of migration then you might be
interested in the talk in a previous
cloud spanner meetup back on july 22nd
on exactly this topic but today
we're going to focus on pocs
and i'm going to start with the
kind of core question
why do we do a poc
so as i mentioned earlier in many ways a
poc is an extension of the assessment
phase a kind of in-depth hands-on
analysis so what drives the poc is
usually the openness and the sorry the
open issues items of concern from the
assessment
so what you want to get out of the poc
is confidence that the migration will
work and that will be cost effective
so typically you're looking to de-risk
core issues those might be related to
handling of load performance latency and
we'll look into this in more detail in
the next slide
or you might want to validate the main
benefits you think you'll get from
spanner so to confirm that spanner will
scale to your workload so pocs as i
mentioned earlier are often a mini dry
run of a migration they help identify
issues you might have missed
and they provide data to better plan out
the full migration
another key role of
pocs is sizing
so how large will your spanner instance
need to be how will you manage sizing
for peak versus
you know drops in traffic and so on so
um you know if i typically i'm going to
have some time where i have way more
traffic and at other times significantly
less traffic how am i going to manage
those peaks and troughs in traffic so
data from a poc
is often critical to coming up with
accurate costing estimates
and finally pocs serve to help you learn
about spanner and use it
effectively so let's talk about some
concrete goals
probably the most basic and frequent poc
goal is a very fundamental one
the spanish scale to my use case now as
i'm sure many of you know
a spanner database is not just a single
machine or even a couple of machines
it's hundreds thousands and in some
cases tens of thousands of machines
working together to provide a massive
strongly consistent database so
the ability to harness a massive
machines and make them behave like one
system and at the same time support
serialized acid transactions and sql
it's really one of the defining
properties of spanner now
many
customers want to see that in action and
understand how it'll work for them and
pocs are a really good way to do that
a related question is load surges
can spanners scale up to surges and then
scale back down again when there's less
load how quickly does this happen and
operationally what does it look like
next is latency
many pocs focus on latency for key
operations they could be reads or writes
some kind of analytic queries or a
combination of all of these and you may
have particular latency percentiles that
you want to achieve maybe at 90th or
95th percentile or 99th percentile so
again this can be another key goal of a
poc
another common question is how many
nodes do i need so this really
represents a trade-off you can run
spanner a bit hotter and use less nodes
but see slightly higher latency and have
less headroom or you can run spanner a
bit cooler
and use more nodes but see lower latency
and have more headroom now we strongly
recommend keeping spanner utilization
for high priority operations under 65
but it's not uncommon to see utilization
around 35 to 50
because of the latency and headroom
benefits it delivers
all right so
pocs can also be used to understand the
scope of application changes that might
be needed in a migration so what code
changes will i need to make to move from
say my sequel or postgres to spanner
usually the focus is on
key components of an application
and the goal of the poc is to get that
particular specific component running on
spanner and the reason for doing that is
we don't want to get all of the pieces
of an application running during the poc
because that's just going to be too much
work
um finally
a poc can be used to investigate schema
trade-offs for example what indexes
should i use how will they impact my
read latency and moreover how will the
indexes impact my right latency
okay
a couple of high-level comments on
planning a poc
so it's really important to establish a
clear scope for a poc
don't try to address all issues or solve
all problems so it's critical to limit
the scope to just the several important
issues maybe three or four issues
and of course having well-defined and
realistic success criteria is important
now usually
you want to pick a core component of
your application stack as the focus of
the poc it could be your main workload
maybe your highest qps workload or the
workload you're most concerned about for
one reason or another and that drives
the implementation part of the poc so
the goal here is to get that component
up and running on spanner
or maybe you'll build a mock of that
part of the application modeling key
aspects of that application component
and get that running on spanner
the main part of a poc will typically be
running this component against spanner
using sample traffic you might have
production traffic that you can replay
or maybe you already have a load
generator or perhaps setting up a load
generator will be a core part of your
poc
for this it's common to use tools like
jmeter or locust as low generators
all right we're now going to switch
gears
and
i'm going to make all of this more
concrete by looking at a sample poc
and i'm going to use a fantasy sports
game as a running example and in
particular i'm going to base this on nfl
fantasy football
i suspect some of you are already quite
familiar with this but many of you won't
be so i'm going to start out by
briefly introducing some of the game
structure to get us up and going
i'm then going to discuss our poc goals
and describe the schema we'll use
and then i'm going to do a brief recap
on some of the internals of spanner that
are going to be relevant to
the poc that we're going to run
and then i'm going to discuss three
experiments we're going to run and
discuss three experiments so let's get
started
so here's a one pager on nfl fantasy
football it's somewhat oversimplified to
fit on one slide but it has the core
parts of the game
so basically
at the start of the season you as a user
playing this game
you get to pick a team of 16 players and
this is usually via something we call
the draft
and that's a process in and of itself
and we're not going to focus on that for
the poc we'll just assume that everyone
has their 16 players
now the core part of the game
is that each week
you get to pick nine starters
you pick a quarterback you pick two
running backs uh you pick two receivers
and so on down this list so out of your
16 players you pick nine as starters so
this leaves you with seven players that
are on the bench and those seven
basically are ignored for that week
um
so
there are some rules about the deadlines
for
when you have to pick your starters uh
in essence you've got to pick them
before they play that week and i'm going
to skip over the details of this since
they aren't really important for our poc
but just note that there is a deadline
and that that means we'll have frantic
users making last minute changes to
their starters before the deadline
all right
so the next key part of the game is how
does scoring work
so you pick your starters and your
starters are really key to this
basically every starter
scores points based on how they do
in that week's nfl games
all of this is based on the official nfl
stats
and then your team score is just the sum
of the scores for all of your starters
and you win that week
if you score more than other teams in
your league so just a quick word on
leagues
typically you have eight to ten teams in
a league or eight to ten users competing
against each other with their teams in
the league but there are tens to
hundreds of thousands of uh leagues
now every week
you can also change um some of your 16
players via trading with other teams in
your league um and i'm going to skip
over that for the moment we're not
really going to focus on that so
there are a number of parts of the
puzzle here and we're going to focus on
just one for our poc and that's handling
team updates so as i mentioned
each week users get to pick nine
starters that translates to traffic each
week from users to change their starters
and for example switching a player who
is currently on the bench
and we expect to see burst of this
traffic before games start for example
users might get fresh information about
player injuries weather conditions
actual team lineups etc and they'll
probably want to make last minute
updates based on this new information
we're also going to assume that we're
handling this for all users across tens
to maybe hundreds of thousands of
leagues so as you can imagine this is
going to generate quite a lot of team
traffic
all right so let's switch to poc goals
whatever what are we going to set as our
goals for this poc
probably the most important goal for our
poc is can we handle the expected team
traffic so let's suppose that today we
see bursts of maybe 5000 to 10 000 qps
of updated team requests
and we're maybe struggling to handle
those bursts maybe we're already running
on a sharded mysql database so a core
part of our motivation for running on
spanner is to scale
easily for our future growth
call it scalability insurance
so we could pick maybe 2x of our
existing qps burst or maybe 5x maybe 50x
for our poc
from a from a spanner perspective it
doesn't really matter too much
internally at google we have spanner
databases that run many many millions of
qps and it's a matter of provisioning
the right number of spanner resources
for this poc we're going to pick a 5x
growth
so that means our goal is to handle
traffic of around about 50 000 qps of
team update request
i've added two other goals to our poc
first
we want to verify that our read and
write latencies are in acceptable ranges
um let's say under 5 milliseconds for
reads 15 milliseconds for rights both at
medium
and around about double that for
99
and the second additional goal is we
want to understand how quickly spanner
can scale up if we need to handle a
burst of traffic
now
note that in spanner
we can choose a single region
or a multi-region configuration and the
main advantage of multi-region is higher
availability so you go from
four nines for a single region to five
nines for a multi-region and the
trade-off is cost so a multi-region
configuration is going to be more
expensive basically you have more
replicas of your data and rights will be
a little bit slower so for our poc we're
going to be using a single region
spanner instance
okay so now let's switch to our poc plan
as we've discussed our main focus is on
team update traffic
and in particular handling bursts of
this traffic that we typically see right
before games start as users make last
minute changes to their
starters we're going to limit our poc to
following scope
we're going to use a population of a
million users randomly generated we're
going to just focus on team update
traffic
and we're going to limit
ourselves to looking at week one of the
season so we'll come back to these
decisions later
the point here is that
when you're running a poc you need to
fix many parameters
and at some level they're educated
guesses and they'll often evolve during
the poc but you need to start somewhere
other to get bootstrapped
and our structure of our run on our
experiments in the poc is basically two
steps step one we're going to generate
and load a million users and their
initial teams and then we're going to
hit our database with 50 000 qps of team
update traffic
all right next
let's talk about the tables we need to
set up to run this poc
so we're going to have two tables the
first is a users table
and the primary key here is user id
this table also has a user's name and
email address and other information we
might need
potentially including information about
how they log in and authenticate to us
we're going to gloss over those
while getting the details of this riot
is critical for an actual migration
for the pocs
these issues often aren't our focus and
in this poc we're going to largely
ignore them
in effect we're going to treat this data
as basically a blob of a few hundred
bytes that we have to carry around but
the content of these bytes isn't going
to impact the running or the performance
of the poc
the next table is the teams table
this is a bit more interesting for the
poc
here is where we store detail uh details
of a user's team so their quarterbacks
their running backs their wide receivers
and also the seven other players on the
bench
um just for putting it on this slide
i'll drop some of those other fields but
you know we've already talked about
what components we need to represent a
user's team so just uh um you know slot
them into the schema here
all right
so um
basically we need all of the information
that
we need to capture a user's roster
in this table
now let's broke it now let's focus on
the primary key used by this table
first we need to have user id
that's pretty clear now i mentioned that
users play in leagues
it's possible and it's actually pretty
common for a user to play in multiple
leagues so we're going to have league id
as a second part of the key so that we
can keep track of the users teams in
multiple leagues
the third component is weak
now the nfl season runs for 17 weeks and
well actually it's going to be 18 weeks
starting this year plus playoffs now
we've chosen here to capture
a users teams for each week of the
season
strictly speaking we don't need to do
this but it's actually a useful um
chunk of information to have because it
allows us to track how a user changes
their team over the course of a season
from week to week and it potentially
allows us to do some additional
validation checks and potentially some
additional
analytics and analysis queries
all right two final points on our schema
first
i've set this up
as um
as an interleave table in the so the
teams table is interleaved in the users
table and this means that a user's teams
will be located together
with the user's data so it allows us to
do efficient joins between these two
tables if needed it also allows for easy
cleanup when we delete a user all of
their teams will be automatically
deleted because of this clause
now in the particular scenario we're
using for our poc today we're not really
going to be running queries where the
interleave tables are going to be
important for performance however just
note that there are many situations
where interleave tables can lead to
significant performance gains both for
reads and for writes
all right the second point i want to
emphasize
is on user id
so this is a really critical part of our
primary key so user id is here the first
component of primary key
and it's a critical part of the primary
key for both users and for teams tables
now in the previous slide we said we
were going to use random user id
generation and this is a really good way
of achieving
a uniform distribution of ids across the
key spaces for both tables this is a
recommended span of best practice and in
particular avoids hot spots and makes a
scalability easy
to explain why
i want to briefly recap an important
spanner concept that of splits i'm sure
some of you already very familiar with
this
but as we shall see it's an important
concept to keep in mind as we're running
a poc
all right
so in spanner
the primary key of each table in a
database is partitioned into chunks
called splits so in this example the
primary key is an integer and the first
split ranges from
minus infinity to minus 100 and the next
split from minus 99 to 3 000 and so on
um
so the same basic things happens for
other types such as strings and floats
and for multi-column primary keys
now
each zone has a copy of each split
so each zone will have a copy of split
zero it appears in different places on
different servers in each zone
but the key point is that each zone has
a full copy of the key space of the
table and indeed has a full copy of the
table's data
you can think of each zone as a
standalone replica and spanner ensures
that each replica stays in sync and has
exactly the same committed data
so what's the role of splits
first splits are the basis for
distributing tables across span servers
and second they form the core part of an
automated sharding mechanism to balance
load across span servers so splits are
not static they're continually on the
move they're continually evolving so for
example if a split is hot and receives
lots of load and contains lots of data
it will be split into smaller splits if
two neighboring splits are relatively
inactive for a long period of time and
they're small enough they'll eventually
be merged
now
it's worth emphasizing
that the starting point
for an empty table is just one split
so when load starts landing on that
table
all of it is going to hit that one split
in other words all traffic for that one
table will go to just three span servers
one from each zone
now suppose i have a hundred nodes
provisioned for my spanner instance
then my capacity when i start with an
empty table is effectively one node out
of a hundred or just one percent of my
total capacity now the good news is that
spanner quickly adapts it can handle 2x
increases and load in a few minutes
but when starting from an empty table we
need several rounds of such increases to
get to full capacity and we'll see this
process in some detail later in the talk
all right so let's switch back to pocs
um and i want to talk a bit about why
splits are important for pocs
so
they're really important for performance
i could have um you know as we've noted
splits are really important for
performance and if i have two databases
with exactly the same data but different
sets of splits
then i'll probably get different
performance if one database just has a
couple of splits and the other has a lot
more splits maybe 10x or 100x more
then we'll probably see substantial
differences in performance between those
two databases so that means to get
repeatable results in a poc
i need to set up similar splits or to
put it another way i need to have a
warm-up procedure that i consistently
use and without this
you risk getting skewed results that are
confusing and misleading
now as we'll see doing a warm-up isn't
that difficult it's mostly about doing
it consistently to get consistent
results
all right let's jump to some experiments
the first experiment
is about scalability and latency
we're going to start with an empty table
then load some data and then send some
team update requests and we'll see the
effect of splits so we'll see
effectively the process of of doing a
warm-up
the second experiment is about handling
overload
by scaling up and the last experiment is
about handling more expensive analytics
queries that involve doing substantial
scans over the database
we're going to look at the performance
of such queries and how they relate to
splits
and we're going to use a query to
actually find out which quarterbacks are
the most popular in our fantasy teams
let's start with the first experiment as
i mentioned we're going to start with an
empty table we're going to load some
data and then we're going to send update
team requests so the initial load
happened here
we were doing
the initial log was doing large bulk
rights in spanner
and they didn't really show up in the
qps so the qps was this was very small
because we were sending large sets of
rights to to spanish so the qps was
probably under about 1 qps just doesn't
show up on this graph
about 10 minutes um after the load so we
did the initial load waited for about 10
minutes and then we started sending
update traffic and as you can see our
qps capacity increases fairly quickly
um reaching about a hundred percent
after about 45 minutes although we do
see some qps variation then it becomes
very stable after about after about an
hour
and so about an hour after the start
we're
um reliably seeing about 55
56 57
000 qps of update team traffic
all right
let's push this graph to the bottom of
our slide to make room for a
cpu graph
and when we say cpu we're particularly
interested in cpu utilization of high
priority operations
so a strong recommendation is to keep
this below this 65 percent level
now you can see that cpu is growing um
over time
and that we stabilize
around 42 to 43
cpu utilization
so what's going on during this ramp up
period
well at the start of this period
all the load is hitting only a small
number of span servers
and they're likely to be running very
hot so those particular span servers are
probably running at 100 utilization and
that's what's limiting our qps now
many of our spam servers at this point
are going to be seeing little or no
traffic they're basically going to be
idle
now the overall utilization um
so the overall utilization at this point
over the entire instance is low
over time
we even out the load
and more span servers see more load and
eventually this load is balanced and we
see an even spread of the load across
fan servers
so that pretty much explains
the the growth in cpu utilization and
how that tracks fairly closely the
growth in
qps
now
early on i mentioned the initial load of
users and it didn't show up on our qps
graph since the qps was so small but we
do see it on the cpu graph
and it's this little blip just before uh
2 30. so
one conclusion here is that the initial
load of user data was just a tiny blip
it didn't take long to do
um and it didn't use many resources and
and
now we mentioned um
uh
that um earlier we mentioned that
spanner splits
are done
based on the load balancing is done
based on the size of data in splits and
the load basically cpu on each split
and in this case our initial load didn't
have enough data or enough cpu load and
wasn't running for long enough to really
stimulate these split and load balancing
mechanisms so this initial load didn't
really load balance
didn't really establish many many splits
it did a little bit but it didn't do too
much and so the real warm-up happened um
when we added the update team's traffic
so if our initial load had included much
more data
had taken longer and used more cpu then
it's likely the shape of a qps graph
would look very different and we would
have seen a much faster qps ramp up
potentially an immediate qps ramp up so
this is something to think about for our
actual migration how much data will we
be loading initially and maybe we should
model that in our poc we'll come back to
this point a little bit later
all right let's switch over to look at
latency
we've dropped the cpu graph from the top
and we've replaced it with latency but
we're keeping the underlying qps graph
as a reference point
so what we see is that
latency
almost looks like a mirror image of qps
initially latency is high and then it
significantly reduces towards the end of
warm-up as tps stabilizes to around
about 56 000 qps
let's dig a little bit deeper into this
the latency graph actually has four
lines um it provides both 50th
percentile and 99th percentile for both
reads and writes
and it's the 99th percentile latency
that is huge at startup so note that the
scale here is actually in seconds so
some of the latencies were
percentile here during startup uh are
really huge
now once we reach steady state and the
warm-up is complete we see the latencies
are much lower
rights are about 10 milliseconds at
median 19 at 99th percentile and reads
are about two milliseconds at median and
around six and a half um
sorry 6.6 milliseconds at 99 percentile
now it's a little hard to see the
behavior of latency over here so i'm
going to zoom in
and just look at the latency in that
chunk of the graph so basically after
warm-up is complete
so we can see a little more about what
are the variations here after warm-up is
complete
and give a more complete picture of
latency so after warm-up our medium
latencies for reads and writes so these
two the purple line here and the green
line here are really solid at about 2
milliseconds and 10 milliseconds
respectively
99th percentile bounces around a little
bit but is mostly under 6 milliseconds
for um reads and
20 milliseconds for
so
writes
are pretty solid numbers and fairly
typical and note that we're running here
at about 43 cpu utilization
all right in experiment two
we're going to consider what happens if
we overload the system
so we're going to crank up utilization
using a warmed up database so we've
already applied our warm-up procedure
we've already established all of the
splits our database is ready to handle
substantial amounts of traffic and we're
going to crank utilization up to over 65
and we're basically going to do this by
reducing the number of nodes to 12. so
that's in this chunk of the graph here
we can see we're running you know around
about 65 sometimes over 65 percent here
and then
what we want to do
is
understand how quickly spanner adjusts
when we add more nodes so what we're
going to do is we're going to increase
the number of nodes from 12 to 30 and as
expected the cpu utilization drops
substantially and pretty much
immediately
but we're probably more interested in
the question
of what actually happens to latency
so to pack all of this on one slide
we'll drop the number of nodes and we'll
use cpu utilization as our reference
grab and move it to the top of the slide
now let's add 50th percentile latency
and you can see that 50th percentile for
both reads and writes doesn't actually
change very much there's a little bit of
ripple here to the left um when we're
running at very high utilization but
mostly we're solid at around about two
milliseconds for reads and 10 to 11
milliseconds for rights
it's a much more interesting story when
we look at 99th percentile and here the
change is dramatic when we were running
at high utilization
99th percentile latencies were up in the
hundreds of milliseconds but after the
increase in nodes they dropped back
by 10x to 30x
so a couple of things to note here um
first on the right hand side we see that
right latency 99th percentile
over on this side of the graph right
latency 99th percentile is about 2x read
latency but on the other side over here
the two latencies are actually very
similar and the likely explanation for
this is that the latencies on the left
are dominated by queuing effects not on
the actual operation executed
second note that the cpu utilization
dropped
when we increased the nodes and it
dropped just before
about 8 15
but the 99th percentile
didn't drop to a bit to a little bit
after 8 15. so this seven to eight
minute difference is basically the time
for spanner to adjust and balance the
splits from hot span servers to the new
span servers that we've added when we
increase the node count
all right
the last experiment
is a sample analytic query and basically
we want to see which quarterback is
picked more frequently and this is
essentially a full table scan and an
aggregation
what we're going to do is look at the
performance of this query right after
the initial data load and then again
after warm-up and a critical tool to
understand the performance of these
kinds of queries is the query
is query explanations and we'll dig into
this in the next few slides
okay so when you run a query using
spanner's
panty on ui you get a page like this uh
and the query is is here now i've added
an additional hint for spanner to use
extra parallelism this use additional
parallelism here um
and i'll come back to this shortly
for the moment ignore it it actually
doesn't have too much impact on the
first query that we're going to run
now what i want to highlight here is how
to get to query explanations so when you
run a query you'll usually land on the
results for that query
but to see the query explanation you
need to click on explanation which i've
circled in bright green
when you click on that
you will see
um an explanation panel
and
that explanation panel has a lot of data
so we'll need to zoom in to see it in a
bit more detail so here we are zoomed
into that panel
now if we focus on this panel we see
that it's made up of three sub-panels
first on the left there is a zoomed in
view of the plan so we can see the
serialized results at the top box of the
um which is the the top box of the query
plan
then next is a zoomed out view that
includes the entire plan although it's
kind of too small for us to really read
carefully and we can see this square
here that shows what's included in the
zoomed in view
okay and on the right is the third panel
which includes lots of stats on the
query
now
in this shade of green i've highlighted
some interesting stats
our query took around about 321
milliseconds to run 322 milliseconds to
run and it consumed about 581 just over
582 milliseconds of cpu so how can that
be we'll dig a little bit further into
the plan
and we're going to do that by basically
dragging down this box and then clicking
on this bottom most
element
which is the table scan so we've done
that this is what we see so we've
dragged down the box we've clicked on
table scans and what we see
interestingly here
is that the um
the right hand panel
um
gives us the stats for the table scan
and note that there are two scan
instances in this particular case so
these ran in parallel um and that's why
the query ran for about 322 milliseconds
but consumed 582 milliseconds of cpu
it also indicates that we've just got a
couple of splits uh in the table so this
first run of the query
we did
just after warm-up oh sorry let me
rephrase that just after we'd loaded the
data so before we did the main part of
the warm-up
now let's run the query again after up
first note that the query only took
about a hundred and just over 100
milliseconds and it was 322 before
now we want to dig into the table scan
operation
at the bottom of the plan
and here's what we'll see so we now have
77 executions so there's a bunch we
could discuss here i just want to hit
a few key points so the key message is
that
there are more instances
of the table scan operation which means
we've got more parallelism so the query
is faster so very roughly the more
splits you have the more table scan
instances you'll see for this query so
if the latency for this kind of query is
important then ensure that your database
is warmed up before you start doing
performance analysis on these kinds of
queries
now i'm promised before to explain a bit
about what they use additional
parallelism
um
what the use additional parallelism hint
was about
so this hint tells spana to maximize
available parallelism when there are
lots of splits and without it spanner
will limit the amount of parallelism it
uses and this is really a protection
mechanism to ensure that one large query
with lots of parallelism doesn't
monopolize the resources of a spanner
instance but in this case our query is
not that large and we're interested in
making it fast so it's appropriate to
use the flag here but you know obviously
you need to use this flag with care
all right so that's all of the
experiments that i wanted to discuss um
but before i conclude i want to go back
to the poc plan that we mapped out at
the start of our discussion and and
basically to do a critique of it so
here's the plan so this is the exact
copy of the slide that we had earlier in
the talk
now some of the limitations that we have
were kind of clear up front
but um you know some of the experiments
also helped us to understand the
limitations of this plan and some
potential things we might like to tweak
if we were to do it again so first we
saw that the million active users
was kind of on the small side
and it led us to a quite small initial
data set with only a few smiths only a
few splits after the load so part of the
issue here was that
in designing the poc
we ramped up the qps so we went from
sort of you know five or ten thousand to
saying okay in our poc we want to do 50
000
we should probably have ramped up the
number of users as well maybe 10 million
users or 50 million users might have
been reasonable
okay so
next
let's
um consider the scope of the poc so we
ran just one week of the season um but
you know the question is will this work
in
week 18
so we'll have a lot more data in the
table
point-wise lookups should be fine but
scans will be more expensive
finally
let's consider how we structure our runs
so basically we generated load and then
ran out team updates
for week one but what about the rollover
from one week to the next so potentially
it's worth tweaking our runs so that we
generate data over a full season and
actually do the rollover of how the team
for one week is essentially inherited
from the team from the previous week
so the overall point here is that in a
poc we typically make simplifications of
the production system and just focus on
core systems and functionality and this
is a trade-off fewer simplifications
mean that
there's more work to do there's a longer
poc and potentially we get overwhelmed
with complexity kind of missing the
forest for the trees
on the other hand more simplifications
mean we might skip or miss important
issues so it's kind of useful to list
out the simplifications you make and
critique them so i've listed a number of
the simplifications we made in the poc
here roughly in order of importance
we've already talked about some of them
but one of them i wanted to mention here
is that all the latency numbers we were
measuring were measured at spanner and
probably um we we should be measuring
some of those latencies both at the
application as well as potentially at
the user side
right
i want to briefly uh recap some of the
best practices we've discussed
um
so the first is
you know to collect reliable and
repeatable results make sure that your
database is appropriately warmed up it's
good to have a standard warm-up
procedure and to use this regularly as
part of your experiment protocol
secondly
don't run spanner or your apps too hot
especially if you're taking latency
measurements so in general we recommend
sort of 40 to 50 as a good target for
spanner utilization
and third
get familiar with query explanations
these are a really effective tool for
debugging and understanding query
performance
okay i want to make one final comment on
tooling
and it's fairly common
when a poc to use data from an existing
database and bring that into your poc
and we've built a tool to help you move
such data sets from mysql or postgres to
spanner automatically it's called harbor
bridge and in our poc we could have used
this to move over a set of users and
their teams from an existing database to
spanner instead of randomly generating
them
so harbor bridge provides the following
functionality it ingests data from mysql
or postgres either using dump or
directly connecting to your database it
builds a spanner schema automatically
and this is something that you can
browse and customize using the schema
assistant mode of harbor bridge it
creates a new spanner database with the
schema and populates it with data from
the source database and it also
documents what it did with a detailed
assessment report so it identifies
issues tells you about features that
weren't mapped to spanner and it tells
you about any errors that are
encountered
all right
let me stop here and uh
take any questions
let me check um
let me check on the uh let's see on the
chat where are we
okay
um so thiago asked
okay why is this only reflected in the
99th percentile uh thiago do you mind
clarifying that question do you mean
yeah sure why is yeah go ahead um so
yeah i was asking about the
when you reduced the number of nodes uh
you kind of saw the effect only on the
99th percentile but not on the other
person tiles i was wondering why is that
only reflected on the tail indices
um so basically when you're running a
system very close to its limits
you know many operations are still going
to perform okay but occasionally they're
going to be some operations
that are going to get caught up and you
know basically get de-scheduled or don't
get scheduled at an appropriate time
because you know the system is basically
really really close to the limit so you
know it's not uncommon for your typical
operation to still run fairly fairly uh
fairly quickly and it kind of depends on
the queuing model and it depends on lots
of other things so for instance if all
queries had to go through a fifo queue
that was centralized then we'd kind of
expect that that queuing latency uh
would show up for basically all queries
but that's not the way that that that
spanner works um you know spanner you
basically are sending queries across you
know a whole lot of different span
servers and there's going to be slight
variations in the um
in the loading of those different span
servers and so many of them will be you
know perfectly fine you know they'll be
at maybe maybe 50 55 utilization maybe
60
and they'll be able to handle your load
just fine summer span servers might be
up um you know at 70 80 utilization and
maybe many of the operations on those
will be um
uh you know will be will we will be
slower so if we push the utilization up
you know to 80 or 90
then i'd expect to see that um you know
the the latency at 50th percentile might
start getting affected or at least the
latency effects of the overload would
start pushing down to lower percentiles
okay yeah that answered my question
thank you
all right
uh any other questions
um
maybe i can ask something else
absolutely
uh did you
did you ever face a situation where a
customer would like to model a larger
part of the application
not only kind of this small scope
and how do you deal with that
so i wouldn't say we've we've um
you know modeled just a small part of
the application this is really a
critical part of the part of the
application so
um you know and i think it's quite
common to pick
one of the most important workloads in
your in your poc um
so something that is you know highest
qps most latency sensitive um you know
most important for users for example you
know my most important part of user
experience so you know i wouldn't say we
pick a small part what we're trying to
do is pick probably the most important
part
um yeah wrong word
yeah yeah yeah i just want to emphasize
you know we're not trying to make this
problem really really simple it's we're
trying to pick perhaps the hardest
problem and then go go go dig into that
um
you know i think the challenge of
picking too many problems is that um the
poc can stretch on for an extended
period of time
um
but you know maybe that's appropriate
maybe there are you know five or six
issues that you really need to drill
down into so at some level a poc can
almost morph into the actual migration
and sometimes you don't really know
where the poc ends and the actual
migration starts um but you know my my
feeling is that you're much better off
um having a fairly well-defined poc
picking picking what you think are the
really critical parts of the system to
model and just focusing on that um you
know there's nothing would you say this
if
if a customer particularly wants to
model many parts of the system
then sure i mean you know that's
something that we would always support
them with um but
it potentially
can consume a lot of resources
and take a considerable amount of time
so you know it's all about focusing on
what's the best value for the time and
investment you want to put into the poc
got it thank you
all right
any other questions
all right looks like there are no other
questions uh so i want to thank you very
much nevin for hosting this session and
thank you everyone for joining um i will
end the recording right now thank you
all have a great morning afternoon and
evening
thank you very much roy thank you